a dancer and a TV this kind of pure
energy the singular it's very important
for the physiological and pathological
conditions but but the function is not
well studied a larger limitation is you
know we are lacking of tools that enable
us to detect this kind of chemical to
know how they can we are there security
oh how they communicate with as a
dancing neurons doctor yourselves yeah
so because it's rush surely there were
similar the ATP ADP an adenosine they
were similar so we need the message that
will enable us to monitor these kind of
chemicals with very good specificity
sensitivity non your v7 is also you know
with the world course which one temporal
resolution yes so that's why we are
developing tools genetically encoded it
to so to achieve this kind of removal
monitoring
yes that's why I'm doing the the
neurotransmitter sensors no someone's
opinion may contradict yours
why is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
Nihao everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alex Akiane we are on site
in Beijing China at Peking University
life sciences we are now going to be
talking about pure energic transmitter
sensors we have dr. Jaffa you joining us
on the show hi thank you so much for
coming on our show
hi Alan thank you you're so welcome I'm
so blessed to be here in Beijing at
school of Life Sciences I love it here
you guys are doing great work and I'm
pumped to be talking about you about
your field those that don't know but
it's a postdoc in the lead lap at Peking
University School of Life Sciences
focused on pure energy transmitter
sensors you can find the link in the bio
below alright fella let's start things
off by asking you what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world oh this
really good question actually I I think
I have I don't know what I have a cool
answer for this kind of question I think
the word now people are becoming rich
they have more and more money right so
but people people care about their
housing though right so but how the
Dacey's happen what how could we kill
well how should we kill this kind of
disease actually from a lot of diseases
we still have no answer right so that's
what I'm really interested in in
specially for the photo the photo
parentis others the people have unknown
not too much around search for these
kind of parentis others so although they
have have a - a lot - well now we have
know something about the parentis others
but not fully understood so that's
that's I think one a limitation is the
the brain very complex array like this
millions of neurons they communicate of
each other so we don't know which kind
of neural neurons on your circuit they
have this kind of that do not work well
so so that's why we need some tools to
you know to enable us to imaging this so
that we can see the neural communication
to say with what kind of communication
is it's changed in the disorder
conditions so that's what I think for
the future for your scientists what I am
seeing about the day and yeah yeah yes
because you you make this good point
that we're getting so much richer and
that people want to live longer they
want to live healthier every single day
but then we have so many diseases that
come up within our bodies and so we need
to understand the brain really well to
prevent some of the neurodegenerative
diseases we need to understand just how
the building better tools to understand
these complex organs like the brain yeah
this is a key point I like that and then
how about where were you born
tell us about your journey how did you
get interested in science I think as a
young young children actually I my
parents they give me some a lot of
freedom you can choose whatever you want
so when I added added I think as a child
in your childhood and as a teenager I
sure I don't know I don't know what kind
of workout I will are we walking on in
the future so part of my parents
encouraged me to try more right you
should so so that's what so I I think
I'm doing science because I'm I do not
hate science and so when I am truly
working on science I think I'm I'm
feeling in love with real science yes
yeah so when I went to college I
actually I I study in the plant science
during the college years yeah and where
were you born
I was pointing the random problems at
China in yeah you know not in the Middle
East over time yeah so yeah and then you
went to the Northwest Western ANF
agriculture and forestry yeah I went to
the Northwest agriculture and forestry
University - for the college so I'm
studying the Plant Protection are there
tangles yeah so when I apply for
graduate school
actually I and because I'm actually I'm
working on the plant protection and in
the college so it's difficult to think
how I changed from the plant science to
the to the neuroscience yeah so we
applied for the graduate school actually
I don't know which kind of major I want
to Oh what kind of science I want to do
in the future let's talk about the plant
science thought that because this is
this is still really interesting stuff
so plant protection your pathogens
interactive plans yes okay so teach us
about what you were studying and
actually with we use the we study
pathogen and and how the repository
interacts with its kind of plant with
that we the plant we are interesting is
the rice and the white yeah so because
when the pathogen in fact the rice you
already they were kinda lost less
production for the for the rice so so
that's very important to know how the
the pathogen interact with the host yes
yeah so so that we can have a way to
treat to you know to plant the to
protect the the plant Tokyo is kind of
pathogens so but how are you protecting
the plant against the pathogens yeah
what were you doing actually we we are
Tony research yeah we want to know the
mechanism how will the pathogens they
can't you know in fact the mmm in fact
that the plants what was the mechanism
for the pathogen to infect the plant
yeah what what is it though they have
different ways the the president's
they're very smart
mmm-hmm they were smart so they have
different ways to in fact the rice all
the other plants so the rest they also
have fit with the pathogens this is kind
of the defeat with each other so they
have different ways the Peregrine have a
different ways they can in fact the the
plant
mmm and the the right rice they can feed
back and defend and the defense back
back different words in different ways
yeah so yeah yeah I think that's weren't
you also a very interesting you know
interactions it turns out those two yeah
especially because rice feeds so many
people probably billions of people
around the world and so in order to
better feed feed people more effectively
you want to study the pathogen
interaction and try and boost up the
plants the Rice's ability to compete
against the pathogen so it can have a
greater yield yet more food more to feed
people yeah yeah yeah and so then that
was for four years and then you decided
to actually I I'm doing a researcher for
two years during the as a grad
undergraduate okay
yeah so I'm studying the plan of
protection we have some costs the biotic
cost not the plant science the plant
pathogen and some insight yes yes our
Silas yes exercise you guys do two years
of general studies Jenner is that and
then two years of specifically for me I
work in the lab for about 22 years yeah
and then how did you decide to come to
Beijing to life sciences here you know
when I am going to graduate from the
college I
decided to do to continue my scientific
career so but which kind of research
should I walk on so at that time back
I should I have no idea so what I'm
doing is I'm you know if you don't know
what to do I'm you you can talk with the
senior person sometime our mentors all
the teachers yeah so I talk about talk a
lot with my teachers so they also the
senior people yeah we thought was so
they give me some suggestions so other
than time I decided to come to Beijing
because in between they have a lot of
scientists they work on different areas
so I went I went to the summer school
either the Chinese academic science at
that time I know a lot of people from
different college different University
which had the walk around different
different different projects so Atlanta
I know not only the plant science but
also the other science that has the
neuroscience all the nearly all the
cancer side cancer science so so where
are in the summer supervising I'll just
give me more chance to know oh you know
what I wanna do yeah yeah I can do
something different yeah so I know after
this time school I went to the picking
inner-city cool so you kind of got a
little taste of cancer science
neuroscience of different Sciences and
then you figured you wanted to pursue
the neuroscience at picking exactly yeah
that's right at that time my mentor dr.
you only give me a give me love give me
opportunity to interview yeah interview
opportunities opportunity so we talk
with each other for at least I think for
more than 55 hours yeah so he gave me a
lot of situations at that time he just
set up the
it gave me a lot of suggestions hey I
think what year was this this was 2012
2013 13 13 13 yes that's it
to soundtrap yeah I was an undergraduate
at that time yeah I went to the the
graduates who added 2013 mm-hmm so yeah
we talked a lot about the future so he
wanted me to give me I offered at that
time to to study in his in his lab so
now after 16 years more than 6 years I
think I have made a good right choice
yeah and well I'm I think I love this
kind of nuisance
yeah when you were first talking to you
long and you were figuring out what your
role was gonna be in your graduate
studies and helping him set up the lab
and all this type of stuff what were you
thinking about that process of helping
him with this process but also with you
figuring out what you wanted to do at
the lab and your undergraduate state or
your graduate studies how did you figure
that out I think sometimes for it so
young for the young undergraduate
sometimes you don't you don't know
exactly which kind of science you want
to do right so it's quite it's not easy
to make a choice to make a decision what
kind of science you want to do so at
that time I think if you don't know what
kind of science you want to do just you
try you try something yes yeah rather
than you'll know you're just waiting you
always try different things and Jain
times any find what you like yeah yeah
yeah oh you can you know talk me this to
my people taco is a senior people to say
which kind of it's 91 mentors helped a
lot happens a lot yeah I think of that
and so then when you guys were setting
up the lab what was your conversation
about for the you know those these last
six years that you've been
doing this more than that how has
they've been setting up the lab helping
with that process also you figuring out
what you wanted to do in your graduate
studies how did you figure that out and
you know when you don't set up the new
lab actually we want to do something you
know totally different we want to do
something peak you know and so so we
decide to you know because in the in the
print what we are studying the boring
science so in the brain they have some
chemicals they called neurotransmitters
they are very important for the neurons
neural communication so but but well
they have some something in some new
when your transmitters your chemicals
they can serve as a neurotransmitter as
item we don't know so we want to study
this kind of question by how we want to
screen to say whether they have certain
kind of chemicals so I so in the in the
I think of for more than three to four
years I'm studying this kind of a
question whether they have some new
chemicals we can serve as
neurotransmitters in the brain so but I
think you at the beginning you know you
know we are we are have a certain
current and so we we don't know well
this can work or not so totally kill me
a lot of suggestions also give me a lot
of freedom you can try you guys explore
a lot but after four years actually
three to four years actually I I think I
this kind of question is a little bit
difficult for the undergraduate students
so I so after four years I give up this
project
yeah so I changed this project to until
another project that's what we're going
to talk maybe in the last few minutes so
we actually the product to focus on them
deriving sensors for monitoring this
kind of pure energy with transmitters
such as Adonis and ITP yeah so I think
when you want other
graduate students as a PhD students and
not only learn how to do research but
also I learned how when you should you
start and initially you give up
sometimes you know because the predicate
is somehow if the project starts for a
long time I think you should a single
person thinking in different ways or you
can't give up
oh please I hold on and I do another
project and then in the future if you're
you got more experience you can go back
to for your for this project
yes yeah yeah this is a very important
point it's that you have when you're
first putting together the lab you're
taking on this big challenge for a
graduate student of trying to figure out
of like can I can i probe this new area
of science and sometimes it's important
to like to say hey maybe I should put
this on hold and I should do something
else for now and maybe later when I gain
more experience I can come back to it so
it's actually that's a really important
point to know when to put something on
hold or to give it up and focus on
something else so then the last two
years or more now being spent on pure
energic transmitter sensors so what is
that pure what is pure nergic so let's
start with that
what is that yeah the pure transmitters
actually there is a class of molecules
they have this kind of pure and group
such as ATP we were familiar with the
ATP right inside of the South the ATP is
a very important energy in a resource
but when the ATP released from the South
you know it can serve as a signal
molecule the ATP and is said it's
derivatives such as the ADP with with
with two phosphate group and attention
without the phosphate group yeah oh yeah
this kind of the class of chemicals they
are called punitive transmitters or
modulators
yeah that's that's this kind of chemical
this channel chemical are very important
for controlling a lot of physiological
conditions for example for our wrist
control the ATP ATP is a very important
for the wrist control and adenosine is
actually very important sleep substance
also called some organs so to know which
what kind of this chemical yeah you
taught me when we first got here ya
happy I want to look it ok and this is
such a nice gift I really for this they
say is this about recalled the caffeine
yeah yeah it's a methane molecule
caffeine molecule yeah yeah so we're
doing a coffee you will feel acid as a
way correct yes
yeah that's why we feel awake that's
because the the okay actually the
caffeine will compete with in Darlington
so Morgan
that's a adenosine so compete with some
organs so people when you drink coffee
you'll feel feel awake so it's very
important for those deep sleep control
so atoms so adenosine is being modulated
in our bodies for sending us closer to
sleep yeah and caffeine when we drink
caffeine the caffeine molecule targets
the same receptors that adenosine is
trying to go to sleep exact into a
blocks bobbylocks
a lot of the Adonis and similarly so
that people will feel as waitress during
yeah yeah so so but for these kind of
molecules is pure native molecules they
they are very important right another
mouthful function of this pure energy
transmission is associated with a lot of
pathological disease such as though you
know the dependent cessation ATP is very
important faucet penalisation pen pen
pen and your Nerium for the mission Oh
neural information under the pen pen
sensation
pen sensation yeah
P P AI n pain sensation yeah yeah oh oh
which which which one ATP is for pain
ATP is very important for pain you said
yeah interesting yeah interesting so and
it so like this so would it be like that
this the cells here
they got secrets the entities ATP to
communicate to the dur the nervous
system to the brain that there's pain
the canal on is separating in the in the
brain and central nervous system they
are also secreting in the peripheral in
this wonderful system yeah but other
than the malfunction with Anna's
incident signaling is associated with
the Caesars epilepsy the malfunction of
adenosine signaling is deals with
epilepsy via also now a public FDA
approved the tracks now it called a is
real-time demo I have forgotten the name
it can attacked it to the attention
receptor the a to a receptor it can be
used as a drug for the treatment of
Parkinson's diseases a castle a FDA
approved the interesting so targeting
adenosine receptors is also for treating
Parkinson's yes
interesting yeah so so the that that
means the adenosine ATP is kind of pure
energy the signaling it's a very
important for the physiological and the
pathological conditions but but the
function is not well studied a lot
limitation is you know we are linking of
tools that enable us to detected is kind
of chemical to know how they can wear
their securities oh how they communicate
with as a dancing with neurons doctor
yourselves yeah so because it's racially
they are similar the ATP ADP an
adenosine they were similar so we need a
method that will enable us to we cancel
our hands okay monitor this kind of
because with a very good specificity
sensitivity knowing your v7 is also you
know with a very cool speech one
temporal resolution yeah so that's why
we are developing tools imaging tools so
electronoggin could keep genetically
encoded the tools so to to achieve this
kind of removal monitoring yeah that's
why what I'm doing the the peer America
transmitter sensors and you were doing
some of that in vivo monitoring in
partnership with Shanghai mm-hmm okay so
tell us about how you can do in vivo
monitoring in imaging spatially
temporally of life adenosine or of ATP
transmission because this is this is
very hard to do how did you get how are
you guys figuring out you know it's I
think it's not easy to a monitor in a
real human right yeah so we use the
model a model system sometimes we're
working on the fly this is a Drosophila
as a model but for me I actually I used
the mice as a model yeah so we can you
know in track one kind interactions a
sensor Enzo is a master burn and we use
the optical measure to monitor this kind
of the dynamics of adenosine during this
kind of city Panabaker service what do
you inject into the mouse your Yuri will
use this kind of virus which one with a
the a a Beaver's a a like a V adenosine
virus and what is it same for its self
all the adenine adenine associates a
virus
I don't mean associates yeah okay yeah
that's where you cannot reuse
virus for the neuroscientist okay yeah
and then that does it so that so that is
a sensor the optical sensor it can't
helps I've become an optical sensor for
imaging
image yeah because yeah so so there's a
sense of Chinese frosting in the bird
and then you can use the optical system
to recall the this signals maybe you can
recover you can't say a single change
that means adenosine release
oh so the virus does what to the neurons
that makes it easier to image what does
it do to the neurons the virus that
can't use process a sensor can express
the sensor yeah yeah okay
oh when it makes it so that you can
image it yeah okay okay
and then you image it with is it with
the long wave is it the body of what are
you using for the optical imaging again
actually use recorded the favo
photometry the photometry yes photometry
yeah so so we can have the the optical
recording and inside a user thing in the
mouse brain I can have a fiber I connect
with the computer so that you can during
the the mouse can free moving okay yeah
the they can sleep also you have this
kind of energy and a yam tree recording
both of those two Wow yeah yes so that a
you will know where the mouse assitive a
week yeah right
so so also you can recall this optical
seen right and how are you this is non
invasively or invasively i think is
computer yeah I think is it's okay yes
but it does go through digital I do you
have electrode glass electrodes in the
brain
yes you do yes okay okay yeah so so it's
difficult to do in a human right but I'm
going to the animals in the mouse yeah
and put them and the mouse can move no
problem yeah after a movie and the
electrics stay in place for reading in
and out yeah yeah I know that's a big
challenge is making sure that uh that if
the mouse is moving that you can still
not damage the neuro
yeah yeah so we already inserted this
kind of optical fiber and before we
recalled so that's the mouse to recover
from one to two weeks at least
yeah so yeah okay
oh so the mouse would recover for for
more than two weeks two weeks yeah and
then you would go again yeah okay okay
okay
yeah I think that's the best way that I
can recall today the the you know record
the signals
that's the passed away yeah interesting
yeah of course we can also do the
imaging you know and uses a two-photon
microscope yes to a meeting in the brain
but it's a two-photon microscope you are
you cannot walk out very deep and you
are deep it can imaging the context for
the most recorder correspond not Verity
you this kind of fell photometry you can
insert the fiber in were deep deep upper
and center yes I think I recall it yes
yes yes interesting yeah okay and then
so then how are you what were you doing
to the them to the mouse you were just
watching okay as it's going to sleep
there's more adenosine and yet what yeah
yeah yeah no that's the first time that
we can enable us to monitor the
adenosine dynamics in real-time during
your sleep and awake cycles so we also
have some interesting funny because we
have these kind of new technologies you
worry they will give us some new
findings for example the people are not
published for example I want to give you
some information that because the mouse
you already they are accurate or in
sleep they have to kind of to castle
city they call the REM sleep under wraps
the Rams researcher has like the humans
are dreaming right during the REM sleep
actually using the traditional method
because they're trimming usually have
overshot period so using the previous
method you cannot you isn't difficult to
record the adenosine levels
ramsley but i without genetical tooth we
can monitor the the in real-time so
that's that's we can know what's
happening here
during the ramp during the mouth hey
Jimmy yeah we have some very interesting
money we are collaborating with the
collaborators either Shanghai as I
introduced with you yeah so so one thing
I want to emphasize is you know four
different scientists you already they
have different expertise right so for us
we are good at deriving this kind of
optical that other genetic include these
tools for for the neural science
neuroscience but people are the other
neuro scientists for example I could add
to understand the brain in the circuit
level for example some of them they're
the one who know what happens in the
facade is in a pathological conditions
so we want to collaborate with the
differences and different I support a
spurt in the field yeah
so that's why I went to Shanghai you
know because he in this group in the
aqualad's
in vivo recording yeah
optical recording so there are also
experts in the sleep and awake studies
so that's why I went year I want to
apply our you know sensors in the in
vivo conditions to first of all to prove
a sense I can work in the in vivo
conditions and that's the use this
sensor or hope we can you know got some
new findings yeah so I think
collaboration with others is very
important yes yes so you take this and
the the adenosine sensor itself for
these pure pure energy sensors
themselves are a combination of what
again the combination of the virus that
you were talking about that enables you
to do the sensing and also then the
optical
the mounted recording yeah so it's both
the virus that gets applied into the in
vivo condition first
in the optical recording with them so
that's the sensor package yeah this is
actually I packed readings of errors so
that is packaging the virus so that
introduces the virus between in fact the
neuron so that is the sense of how he's
passing the neural the sensor is
packaged in the virus and it's you said
it's genetically encoded so then you you
you do you edit the virus so that it mmm
that when a it gets expressed by the
neuron then it enables the optical
imaging so you you had to edit this
virus to make it yeah let's do the
sensing yeah but also Ewan ethically
encode yes the virus this virus is they
have such as such a carnival serial type
so you know they they can carry these
sensors you can change different sensors
so the virus can carry these sensors and
to in fact the the neuron and whereas
these kind of sensors in the neural
doesn't make sense see it one more time
so the virus so you can package the
severity the those sensors different
sensors for example adenosine sensor the
calcium sensor the 80% Oh different
sensors you can't actually individually
in the virus to so the virus can you
know carry these kind of sensors and
three factors in Iran so there is a
sense of Chinese press engine cool so
the virus actually and we use this verse
as a tool also to carry our
carry our sensor sensor yeah yeah 20
fires is used as a tool to carry the
different sensors for adenosine or ATP
etc into the neurons which then it gets
expressed which then makes them able to
be image yeah yeah okay so this is civil
yeah I I think I wish we we shouldn't
talk too much about the virus you know
we'll make people are you out of there
yeah well sometimes when we talk to
about the viruses sometimes people say
that that the virus is there's a you
know do you have to fight against the
immune response there's an immune
response by the body yeah you have to
fight against that
yeah then sometimes the virus I heard
different viruses only last for whatever
a couple weeks or months or whatever and
then they just fade away yeah
so for the near Sundays we we engine not
ask so the people have an engineer these
kind of words to make it a very safe so
that we can use the the words to carry
out the dreams who we want until we in
fact the cells including the New Orleans
yeah so so they are very safe because
they are engineered also they are rather
used for the neuroscientist yeah yes
yeah but I think people they don't know
too much about that people really care
about it is no better but if it's
engineered like you said specifically to
carry a tool and for research for
research and also that it's being done
on mice for now and then we can prove
maybe that it can be done with humans
and it can be done safely yeah this yeah
yeah it's hard to test if it's safe
because it has to be you know several
years down you have to see if there's
any effects yeah it's very hard to tell
yeah yeah yeah okay how about the most
interesting applications of this so okay
you build these pure energy transmitter
sensors and then you have what are their
uses besides in vivo imaging you know
where do you want to see this used what
could it be optimally used for
as a circle question so we are you know
we're developing these kind of wood
tools one of the tools to solve some
problem or question to answer some
questions for example I single for as I
introduce the darkness and signaling or
the pure energy single mone they are
very important for not only is a fedora
Keynesians but also for the pathological
conditions so I think the NASA question
is were interested also very interesting
and a very important is what happens
what's the dynamic change of this kind
of pure American transmitters in the
pathological conditions such as during
the epilepsy whether the dancing
released is a change or not aware did we
are the denizen change that I make a
change so actually still have no answer
so also I introduce Tennyson also very
important for the Pakistan TCC's right
so it rains or Parkinson's diseases the
dynamics of adenosine how did it
adenosine dynamics change so Nestor I
think oh we will apply our sensors not
only in of physiology condition but also
in the pathologic condition to help us
to understand the mechanism for the
quality didn't happen at least in from
our the newer the parametric transmitter
perspective yeah
so that's I think the applications of
this it's interesting so it's the big
part is the the understanding the
mechanisms of disease yeah
pathology developing of the fit of
physiology first and then the pathology
people yeah yeah yeah interesting ok so
right now is the physiology study yeah
we have some preliminary data onion the
a privacy so so now we demonstrated our
sensor can't attack to this adenosine
release during the epilepsy yeah so in
the future if you can apply from Maltese
model exactly yeah yeah because the we
want to know regarding trans and neural
transmission we want to know about where
the miscommunications are happening
where the diseases are happening with
the pathologies are being developed so
by on building these sensors for all of
the different neuro chemicals then you
can best understand how disease that's
what our lab are trying has been are a
lot of efforts on dividing the tools to
monitor this kind of neural chemicals
yes the encoding will appear when
there's your transmitters yeah yeah so
ideally down the line in the future
let's say that the lis lab and many of
the other labs your work and many other
neuro scientists work across the world
enables us to have the full chemo
connectomics
of the brain okay what will we be able
to do Bert I guess first is what would
be the tool that would let us do the
full chemo connectomics what would be
the ideal neuroscience tool for that and
to when we have that tool and we have
the full chemo connector which is ready
all the time what will that enable us to
do prevent disease stay healthy be
smarter what will embarrass news first a
tool second what would from my
perspective I think first if we want to
make a some change for example you can
you want to be is matter it's a matter
bit won't be most mad or you want to
to kill to treat the disease the first
step is to know so which kind of veneer
circuitry which kind of chemicals they
are controlling this kind of piece Matt
OH for example for controlling Delaney
on the memory or controlling the
Pakistan the amount function you have
these kind of diseases
so the first icing you should know the
mechanism how how the brain works first
that's the first time then you will know
what changed in the ended up disorders
right so I think the first step is tuned
to understand the brain and then to
change the brain right so I think to
Anna Steinberg brain is the first time
so we need some tools when you it is
kind of imaging tools so when you have
this eye sensors for example you should
have the microscope all the optical
imaging tools right not only the sensors
but also the microscope right also the
how to deliver these tools in the burn
you should have this kind of tools as a
continue for the delivery for example
the virus as I introduced so yeah so
after these kind of tools sometimes
maybe you can only work in the model
system the in the Drosophila in the
mouse and asked how to use on your
understandable after you understand
brain in the model system so that is
consistently in the in the human brain
right so you should should also have the
tools that imaging or you can you know
know what what happens in the brain you
know especially in the human brain
right so I think that and we are trying
effort to understand the operon
a difference in the neuroscientist that
we work on different perspective a
different aspect so we are trying to you
know make us to know the brain to
understand the brain and then know make
some change or to treat the disease
that's my understanding yeah yeah yeah
okay so the tool set is so important for
us to understand the brain to have the
chemo connectomics of tool set first
then when we have it then it's enabling
augmentations a healthier state brain
states all these types of things happen
okay yeah how about now that we have the
exponential technology H happening the
democratization of so many of the of the
information technologies what do you
think is a skill that young people
should know around the world
mmm-hmm I think the first thing is you
should have your own thoughts
yeah you should you know I think is very
important to think and the ability to
learn you know we have a lot of
informations you know you you can learn
from the from others also from from an
expert for example also from the senior
person or from my uh peers from
collaborators so so the ability to learn
it were also very important so I think a
to two things firstly you have your own
source a second answer you should have
the ability to learn yeah that's yeah I
like those two yeah yeah yeah those are
very good especially in a world where
we're constantly having information come
at us to be able to understand which one
is the most important for me to learn
mm-hmm yeah yeah for me to take in yeah
yeah and then how about you know
collaborating across the world how can
we increase collaboration for both
scientific research but also just
increasing global harmony how can we
best do that around the world I think
for the collaboration you're the first
lady for the open my own money right you
should um you know when your clubs are
others you should you should open be
open right you know sometimes you had
something your toner told all all of
what you are doing to them so I I don't
like this kind of so you should talk
talk
what do you have and to know how to to
know the ice buddies and ask them for
help and I think the most important open
money if you have open mind yeah yeah
yeah I like that a lot and
open-mindedness is so important and it
also makes it easier for us to know that
we can learn something from everyone
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you should
let people know what do you have what
you need right yeah yeah yeah yes yeah
yeah like that
how about what do you think is the
meaning of life of this big human
experience what is the point of it
there's another of our big question
right yeah typical to answer the meaning
of life hmm I think for me as a you can
call me a young scientist yeah so I
think from my perspective so first I
should do my you know what so I think
you should be a good person first yeah
so I took a good people you know you be
kind to others right yes yeah - that's a
force as a human there should be of a
kind of person yes as I said this I
think you should have your own own I
don't know how to say - not across the
rows the
across the lines you know you're sure
the callee conclusion based on your
result oh yeah yeah if be scientifically
accurate and yes and
and and and scientifically Oh honest I
be honest
yeah yes as a as a human and as a
scientist you should be honest so after
that you can think about the meaning of
the meaning of your life interest so so
I think that the first step is to be the
big hand and the be honest yeah
a nest I think if I can do something you
know why not hold as a neuroscientist if
we can do something maybe it's worth
small but we can have us to understand
how the brain works or the happen you
love diseases so I think I ever have I
can do something in my whole life that
can help us to understand these kind of
questions I think that will be worried
meaningful yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think yeah yeah yeah another thing I
think other scientists I see you know
sometimes we we were to communicate with
the art each other
Minister Odom you know you it's
difficult to know every person right but
what we can learn is from they are
public publish the papers yeah so so so
that we can know their works
so when sometimes when you read a lot of
people a lot of paper published the ban
word one person when you meet her meet
him you will feel wow it's you it seems
that we are familiar with each other you
know so I think that's very excited you
know I read a lot of people for example
from the big name in the field when I
met with him
I will see Wow we know I know him
maybe he don't know me right and so I
know him so he looks like a my you know
mentor
yeah I think that's a worry you
fantastic very very interesting kind of
scenes for other scientists so so we
have our own way to communicate
communicate
yeah we will know mr. no the rip real
person that have you amazing yeah yeah
yeah
and then how about consciousness do you
feel like consciousness is part of our
biological phenomenon that comes up do
you think consciousness may come from
somewhere and take its seat in the body
what do you think I have I think I think
I have no idea of how the question is
but I think I wish was which was
thinking you know Santa Fe away not the
god yeah I'm not sure I understand it I
think we should know and I I'm Nadia
mm-hmm this is a very hard one to and
I'm just we love asking about
consciousness is such an interesting one
and then how about do you feel like we
have free will
I think so yeah and why hmm I don't know
and that's some personal idea yeah yeah
well I have not here yeah but you think
so okay yeah and what do you think is
the role of love in life
the role of Allah yeah life on a lot I
think you know sometimes when I work in
the lab I think that's kind of I love
this kind of doing experiment for
example yes yeah well you yeah I think
the work is my life it's a part of my
life yes not and yeah all right to
singer that's a good answer yeah
yes
yeah yeah I also feel lots of love when
I do this you know yes it to me if this
is love you know so I think doing
something you are interested in that's
kind of make you happy that's you will
feel loved right yeah yeah
also when sometimes you know the tuning
instrument is tip is difficult you
cannot you know catechu do that
yeah most of them where we have a lot of
videos yeah at that time if you you know
you know so well go back home so my wife
she can give me a hug I will feel loved
yeah yeah yeah yes so I think post the
work and family yes that also there all
were were very important for me yes yes
yeah yeah yeah the family is also
important the family is also love yeah
though the spouse or the child these are
love yeah husband the wife the child
types of things mm-hmm what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world you know as an undergraduate so
when when I have as a class so the the
the our teacher you already show us a
lot of the pictures for the for the
bacteria's forum or for the fungi so we
can see either fungi with a large skill
they are very beautiful yes so that this
the fungi is also weren't beautiful but
if you think a large the out brain is
also very beautiful
the the neuron the look so they have
this kind of cell body this neurites
this tendrils axons
we can send of our lung projections from
one to another so if you can label the
neurons with different color you looks
like a per input like a pole we called
foreign bow I think they were involved
this is I think this brain
communications if you can visualize this
communication burn burn sales I think
that's where beautiful part yeah yeah
yeah yeah and on undergraduate I think
as a fungi this bacteria they are very
beautiful and you know in macro in the
very small world right yeah where small
circuit if you enlarge this skill they
are also very beautiful but of for the
paren now we can recall if you can
visualize this neuron communication then
neurons I think they are also a few yeah
yeah yeah I agree I agree this has been
such a fun conversation yeah thank you
very much for something on our show
sometimes on time thank you so much yeah
this has been very enlightening there's
this is a really interesting subject
pure energy transmitter sensors and also
what the plick abilities are for our
future for understanding the physiology
and the pathology of it and having
better health over time and but just
building better tools for understanding
the brain yeah that Congrats on all the
great work so far yes but it seems you
know I haven't always been published yet
so I hope I can you know publish is our
source of that work yeah so that the
people the all of the world their entry
if they're interested you can you know
they can use these kind of tools you
know understand the report yeah yes yes
so keep yeah keep going like this is
this is really great so the public
publishing of new tools for brain
research can then inspire more
scientists around the world to use those
tools or also to make new tools
themselves yeah yeah I totally agree
this is really this has been super fun
for those again that want to you know
get involved get involved let us know
your thoughts in the comments below
thank you very much for tuning in we
really appreciate it
we'd love to you know hear your thoughts
in the comments below on the episode
we'd love for you to check out the links
in the bio below have more conversations
through your friends families co-workers
people online about pure nergic
transmitter sensors and about the
subjects that we talked about building
these better tools for the brain and
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders around the
world that you believe and support them
help them grow support simulation our
show you
find all of our links in the bio blow to
support us and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we'll see you soon
peace peace allowed that's it that was
really fun I had a really good time I
still have a very good time that's the
first time you know no communication I
good I love it
good good
[Music]